in the twitch chat chewy chocolate chip
okay let's go at night f6 again let's
try it again are we gonna enter or what
are we gonna see d5 no we're not getting
d5 and b5 mmm do I play g6 and still
allow for maybe push and then b5 hmm
let's give it a whirl a whirl is okay
well I wouldn't have b5 in response to
d5 anymore so it's things get developed
and what have we entered here we are
entering by transposition a very slight
transposition what name this physician
who knows castle
yes I just caught it einsteinium Z
coming in first with that one
Murdoch marcozzi buying Roxy bind I'll
know which one it is someday anyhow the
bind a bind on the d5 square the c4
dragon ah what do you do here what do
you do make things easy here I see six
all right let's go are you gonna take my
knight should I be scared
should I be scared of that I take with
the pond and the pond says aha
night you can't go to any fantastic
places alright Bishop here should I be
worried about doubled pawns maybe oh I
don't know I don't know what to do I
don't like this position Bishop here
Bishop here one of these two I want to
do Bishop d7 maybe I don't know what I
want
oh man none of the above I guess let's
try this now I know where my bishop
wants to be you target this pawn real
quick if this move comes in trade
bishops and then maybe get on these dark
squares trade Queens I'd be happy with
that
hmm
No what's the plan here I really don't
like this position for black it's not a
bad position but it's just something
that I'm not a giant fan of and I wish
my computer would shut up it's going
crazy and you're having a tough time
here the fans this seems right throw the
knight in the pin this square is weak
and maybe my queen wants to play here a
six B five one day rook F 2 C 897 be
aware of this Knight maneuver oh there's
also this possibility and I think I'm
actually netting upon you follow this
tactical shot tactics tactics tactics
everywhere sneaky stuff they take spawn
I'm on the Queen I takes Knight Queen
takes Queen check regardless of how that
Queen is recaptured at the end of it I
pick up the big bad dark square bishop
all right be aware of this tactic I
think castle's was best there just get
castled
well what are we gonna do we're gonna
enter endgame land with black being Appa
pond might as well pre move that there's
nothing better unless the king goes to
f1 so easy to fall for that tactic and
make no mistake it is something that I
too have fallen for so for whatever
that's worth I guess rest easier knowing
that I to fall for those tricks I fall
for those tricks too
yes I do h6 I think I like that move
let's go h6 why in the world would I do
that I don't want this Bishop to be hit
the king is gonna move and give my
bishop of beating king improvement I
guess I could have considered all right
there was a threat then actually after
this move pawn push I don't have very
many choices now I couldn't come all the
way back here's something I want to be
cautious of actually let me give a check
or should I now now let's see this
opposite colored Bishop endings be
cautious of those I'm up upon oh and I'm
also down on time I I totally blanked
out right there what am i time go if
Knight here I want to play back jeez I
think I got caught up in just blabbing
if I give up my Bishop for this knight
or excuse me if I give up this Bishop
for the night we have an opposite color
Bishop ending in it's much more
difficult to put to use my material
advantage I want to get in b5 and I
could maybe get that in
a bits a bit sooner than I once thought
because I have that Bishop a5 move with
tempo so this is a crumbling here which
is a nice to see and I might have
something with f5 and rook here but let
me just I don't have time to calculate
that so this King can't feel too excited
about the position right now he's kind
of running out of squares and these
bishops are probably gonna give him a
giant headache soon okay well what do
you do here you move fast and okay you
actually move fast let's do this
and Oh ma'am you move this pawn so it
doesn't get taken and you hope to one
day get to this square somehow with 30
seconds oh man there had to be a better
way to go about things if King he okay
this Knight get out here because you're
a giant pain definitely a giant pain I
need to get out okay he doesn't have
very many choices
let's go bishop bishops gonna have a
nice home right here on c5 and no I
don't want to trade I probably should
have given a check my rook what is my
rook want to do let's give a check here
beyond that 922 tikka Rooskies easy
night he was ready to get here now I
need some king improvement let's go King
contribute be a contributor
hang on don't drop this pawn either and
I'm ready to drop that pun it's scary
capture towards the center let's have a
good reason not to get out of there
Knight Holmes where's the home for the
night watch out for those homes
let's go King position King position my
opponents flying
oh that's dropping a piece oh oh this is
big trouble now or we're gonna have
resign which is 10 seconds we do the
mouse was not being tested
it wasn't being put to the test I think
most people would do that I'm okay if
you do do that that's okay all right I
mean I'm not saying like I'm gonna be
able to win but hey take it take
advantage of the fact that I wasn't
moving quicker earlier okay good game
let's back up let's see what the plan is
here what's the scoop so I wonder what
that what's the deal with this H pawn
move what's what's the scoop
I've seen aged three and then as a
follow up g4 and Bishop here I think
I've seen something like that but if
you're gonna stop I guess the knight
move to this g4 square and I think that
that was the intention my opponent has
with this h3 stop Knight g4 and you know
it's going to then secure dark-squared
bishop position on e3 well I guess
another I guess a drawback is that you
know you open up your King to this
diagonal if you're playing f3 where as
h3 don't so okay that's so good
understand that it's different I don't
see myself any better right here okay
yes I went upon at this point and then I
I do poorly with my clock management but
right here I think after you castle what
I do
I was planning on playing rook c8 like
if you just Castle here I'm not gonna
win upon rook c8 I guess I could still
be trying for a 6 B 5 and in the
meantime what can white be doing
you still can't play this Queen move so
be again be aware of that
Queen d3 whether castle door castled and
playing that Queen - this D 2 squared
still not working out because of that
tactic how could white be making
improvements I wonder if there's
something with f4 and looking for a 5 or
really don't know or maybe just posting
up this Knight right here something like
Queen d3 maybe your your f rook over to
c1 and then playing your knight to this
d5 square I think you should be looking
into that move but yeah things certainly
turn when down upon and we're in this
endgame here note no Queens and I don't
know if I made the correct decisions in
this endgame my biggest problem was just
time but okay again I fell for that
tactic more than once I believe in blitz
it's it's an easy one to fall suspect
too